un nouveau carburant arrive dans les
yvelines une station d'hydrogène a été
inauguré ce mercredi 28 mars aux loges
en josas cette énergie verte fabriqué à
partir de ressources renouvelables en
normandie ne produira ni gaz à effet de
serre ni particules fines
la recharge se fait en quelques minutes
à la pompe pour un prix équivalent à
l'essence c'est le même usage qu un
usage diesel ou essence
à la différence de la batterie ou vous
devez chargé des électrons là vous
charger directement du gaz dans un
premier temps la station sera utilisée
principalement par des bennes à ordures
des taxis présents sur le territoire et
deux bus à hydrogène sur la ligne 264
qui dessert les villes de buc et de
versailles on commence par les premiers
parce que ça permet développer des
logiques de flottes captives qui
reviennent sur les stations donc ça
permet de charger les stations plus vite
et de les rendre rentable plus
facilement mais la vision à long terme
c'est que vous avez aussi des voitures
particulières
j'ai quelques collaborateurs aux états
unis qui tourne sur deux voitures sur
les voitures hydrogène avec plaisir vous
avez plus de 7000 véhicules dans le
monde qui sont des véhicules
particuliers une vision à long terme qui
a séduit l'agglomération de versailles
grand parc
c'est l'enjeu du 21e siècle comment
sauver la planète mais toutes les
entreprises essayent maintenant de
s'inscrire dans cette nouvelle dynamique
coût total de ce projet 1,5 million
d'euros pour être rentable la station
doit accueillir entre 50 et 60 véhicules
par jour à terme la station prévoit
également de ravitailler en carburant
des vélos à hydrogène